in the midst of a rain delay where has
rained most of the day on again off
again and they have just recently taken
off the tarp they tell us they are
aiming for a 355 par-time start time
trevor cahill facing the san diego
padres numbers to date lee hill will
improve quite a bit on those numbers
this evening jay kronenworth leading it
off for the padres in this order tonight
this one is turned on it's sending to
right field a base hit for cronenworth
to get the night started he walked him
first and second here is manny machado
02
got him hay hill strikes out machado
sweeping action as that ball went from
the inside corner to the outside corner
now hosmer hitting 353 with three home
runs another one two
yes there's that curveball again
back-to-back strikeouts after the single
in the walk machado and hosmer on will
myers who stands in on the right side
this is in the air to left field and
it's gonna get in for a base hit around
from second base is cronenworth he'll
score and the padres take a one-nothing
lead profar stops at third and a big two
out rbi single for will myers has the
padres on top you darvish has got a run
with which to work here as he takes the
hill for his third start 34 year old 262
opponents batting average third start as
a padre two ground ball outs for you
darvish out of the gate here two-way
base is empty for brian reynolds on the
ground and it'll be hosmer at first base
he'll flip to udarvish for the out that
ends the first inning colin moran is
that cleanup man
for the pirates
and he takes it the other way and
diving to make the catch out there and
left is profar
sinking line drive and he makes the
catch
kind of pointing out towards the light
banks i don't know if that got into the
way of his vision or not coming in but
he makes the catch here's justin fowler
swinging a miss and darvish picks up his
first k of the night jake cronin worth
he singled his first time up frazier
the first out
he has four strikeouts through two
innings takes strike three
fastball right down the middle
and cahill has struck out five padres
one nothing san diego in the bottom of
the third kevin newman will lead off
this is on the ground to the third and
machado off balance and plenty of time
nice play by manny machado say that over
and over and over again
makes it look easy down there at third
he most certainly does and this is not
an easy hop for the padre third sacker
so after the wild pitch advancing
frazier base hit here with two outs
could tie this game bounce to third
that's fair pass machado as the double
for philip evans ties the game at one
hill struck him out to end the first
inning hitless in his last four games
bounced to third and you can see
gonzalez
played on that short hop
so that's the second out and hosmer at
second base he had that glove way closer
to where that ball is bouncing so even
if it bounces a little funny it's just
going to hit a different spot in the
glove
and now carratini
and bounce to frazier
cahill again as a runner one out in the
fourth inning and that brings up eric
gonzalez
2-2 pitch
and that one's by him at 95. strikeout
number two for you darvish two down here
in the fourth inning straight challenge
time right there yes it was and pinpoint
control at 95. you demand two outs in
the fourth inning brings up jacob
stalling
that one is lying sharp play to third
and manny machado is there to make the
catch my son kim gets off bounced to
short in the second
big
cut down on strikes
number six for cahill turned out to be a
pretty nice strikeout night for cahill
gets another
number seven see what he does here with
two outs and profile coming up 3-2
and a swing and a missy struck him out
went right back to it the exact same
pitch great job of executing by trevor
cahill throwing that breaking ball down
back foot 1-1 the score both teams with
three hits neither with a miscue we head
to the bottom of the fifth and hugh
darvish back out there
swinging a miss and darvish picks up his
third k second time fowlers down by way
of the k
boy the late break on this breaking ball
is really nasty two outs of the bases
empty oh and two to polanco and the
pitch is swung on in miz darvish got him
and now four strikeouts for you
including a couple here this inning one
out runner in second fires one for two
that's single in the first myers drives
one in the air out to deep center field
and gone
two-run home run for will myers his
third of the year and the padres take a
3-1 lead
will myers with a two-run shot he has
driven in all three friars runs
you know don we've heard some balls off
the bats of uh rangers on this road trip
of padres on this road trip and you know
what they just don't seem to travel i'll
tell you what this one that is squared
up
big time will knows that he's got it he
goes right into the shrubbery victor
caratini go for two he's fly to right
and grind it out to second base this one
is lying sharply out towards zipline
center field and it's by the dive a
fowler fam is gonna head around the
bases he is around third and headed home
throw will not go to the plate and the
padres will take a 4-1 lead victor
carratini driving in tommy pham and the
padres are on top four to one one down
in the sixth inning eight in a row
retired by darvish and brings up philip
evans here's a one-two swing and a miss
got him to go chasing the breaking ball
in the dirt strikeout number five for
udarvish continuing to roll right along
here through the pittsburgh pirates